The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: My name
is Mark Harvey
and I'm currently
teaching a course called
Musical Improvisation.
And this demonstration is part
of that course in collaboration
with [? Mitas ?]
and Phil Scarff,
who's the leader
of Natraj, which
presented a great
concert yesterday.
I know some of you were there,
but if you weren't there,
maybe you'll be able
to hear Natraj again
in another setting.
And so, Ravikiran is
the other presenter.
He'll be coming a little bit
late, but he will be here.
So we're going to
begin with Phil.
PHIL SCARFF: So
today's workshop is
going to be on
application of frameworks
from Indian classical music to
improvisation in other idioms.
And in Indian classical music
there are two major systems.
They're really two
different idioms.
There's North Indian
classical music,
which is also called
Hindustani music.
And there's South
Indian classical music,
which is also called
Carnatic music.
So I'm going to be talking
about Hindustani music today.
And our guest
Chitravina Ravikiran
will be covering
Carnatic music after I
talk about Hindustani music.
So it'll be interesting to see
the contrast between the two.
So you might want to
pay attention to that.
So what we'll do is,
you've got a handout.
I see people seem to have
that, so that's good.
So I'm going to talk
about a number of things
that are outlined
on the handout.
I'm going to demonstrate
some stuff as we go through.
If you have questions feel free
to raise your hand or whatever
as we go, because I'd
rather take the questions
as we go than lose people if
I'm going off on a tangent
and you don't follow me.
Probably other people have
similar questions, too.
So what I'm going to
do to start with is,
I'm going to present an
alap in raga Hamsadhwani.
For those who were at
the concert yesterday,
we played the piece "Red Swan,"
which is in raga Hamsadhwani.
So this sort of ties
back to the concert.
I'm not going to go
too much into the nuts
and bolts of ragas.
There'll be a little bit of
discussion here and there as
needed to cover the
frameworks, but this
is more about sort
of a higher level
view of Indian
classical music and how
the frameworks
from that music can
be translated to
other situations.
So I'm going to
play an alap, which
is an exposition of the raga.
It's done kind of solo with
no percussion, just melody.
And it starts out without meter.
And it can evolve
to a point where
there's sort of an
internal meter going on,
but there's still no percussion.
So what I want you to
do is listen to this
and pay attention to
some of the things
like how we're
making use of range,
note density,
rhythmic development.
Well, mainly those things.
We'll talk about some
other things afterwards.
But listen for those
things and then we'll
discuss them after I finish.
[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
OK, so did anybody notice
anything about range--
the use of range in that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It seemed to start
in the lower end of the range
and slowly build up to
through the entire range.
PHIL SCARFF: Yeah, that's right.
Very good.
And this is very typical
of a Hindustani alap.
It starts around the low tonic.
It may kind of build into it
and work a little bit around it,
but the focus is going to
be on introducing that tonic
and sort of
establishing the tonic.
Then, you can
optionally move down,
which I did a little
bit of, and you
can expand the range downward.
Then you can start expanding up.
And you go up kind
of sequentially.
It can be note by note, it
can be phrase by phrase,
but more or less it goes
sequentially upwards.
And then as you do
this development,
then the range expands.
We're not moving a
confined range upward,
we're expanding the range.
So as this progresses, then, we
use more and more of the range.
And then there's a resolution
point at the upper tonic.
And then it can
optionally continue
above that, which I
did a little bit of.
And then the range again then
starts condensing back down
and comes back to the Sa.
And then, depending
upon the tradition,
the performer may decide then
to do another section where
it goes into more of a
rhythmic presentation.
So there's like an
internal time going on.
And so I did that next.
And then, so what other
things did people notice?
Are there any comments
about, say, density of notes?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Well, not
about density of notes,
but noticed that you only
used a few notes of the scale.
I think four or five.
PHIL SCARFF: Yeah, that's true.
I used five notes because
this raga only has five notes.
So, yes, it's a pentatonic
raga, so only five notes
are there in the raga.
So in most ragas, you don't go
outside whatever the notes are
that are defined as
being part of the raga.
You don't go outside those.
Occasionally, there are
some ragas, exceptions,
where you do.
But for the most
part, you don't.
So that's why I
stuck to five notes.
But you're right
about that, good.
That's good observation.
So any observations
about note density?
How it may have varied
or developed or evolved?
Or, say, frequency of notes.
How long did the notes last?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The ones at the top
or the bottom of the range
were usually longer.
PHIL SCARFF: OK.
That's a good observation.
When I started out, I was
playing much more sustained.
When I got up to the
high tonic, I also
sustained a bit, that's true.
And any other comments?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It was progressive.
So you started out
with long notes
and you progressed and went into
faster and more diminutions.
PHIL SCARFF: Yes, that's right.
So the notes came
faster, at a faster pace.
A higher density of notes.
It started out with fewer notes,
much more contemplative kind
of playing.
And then as this
involved, then the notes
came at a more rapid
pace gradually.
So that's another thing.
So note density's
another framework.
Oh I forgot to mention.
Now, what I wanted
to do is, I'm going
to talk about each
of these frameworks.
And I'm going to talk about what
is the tradition in Hindustani
music, and then also
how can we extrapolate
the tradition in other ways,
maybe changing a parameter
here or there to use
the same kind of idea,
but extrapolate it and
make it into something else
and then also apply.
You can apply the
tradition directly
or you can apply
the extrapolation.
Any of those things
are possible.
So of course, we
talked about the range.
That can be applied directly
to another improvisation
in another style.
But we can also make
changes to the range.
So instead of starting
on a low note,
we can start on a high note.
And we can build the range down.
Instead of building
the range up,
we can build the range down.
Or maybe we can start
with a very wide range
and then condense
it down and then
focus on a note at the end.
So there's a lot of
different possibilities,
things you can do
with the range.
So that's the framework.
And then the idea is, you
can use the parameters
from the tradition,
or you can adjust them
and make some
changes and come up
with some new ideas for
other improvisations.
So the same with note density.
So does anybody have any ideas?
What could we do with
note density that
might make it a little different
from what you heard just now?
Any ideas about what
we could do instead
of starting with
long notes and then
progressing to short notes
and faster lines, what
are some other things that
one could do in a performance?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Keep the same
density throughout.
PHIL SCARFF: You could keep
the same density throughout.
That's right.
That's one option.
Any other options
you can think of?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You could
play backwards.
PHIL SCARFF: You
could do it backwards.
Exactly.
Yeah, exactly.
Those are all great ideas.
So you could do it backwards.
You could start with very
fast lines, very rapid notes,
very rapid passages,
high note density,
and then work your way back down
to a very slow, longer notes,
less dense presentation.
So another thing is,
in Hindustani music
we have a thing
called chalan, which
refers to things like
characteristic phrases
that are used over and
over in compositions
and in improvisation, a
kind of thematic material
that comes back.
And so that can take the form
of actual melodic fragments.
Or it can also be
rules like, you may not
play a certain note in
ascent if you played
another note before it,
and things like this
can also be part of the chalan.
So one thing that I was
doing, and I'm not sure
how apparent this
might have been,
but some phrases that are
common in Hamsadhwani.
First of all, many times--
[PLAYS F-SHARP] we start
on the third and
end on the second.
So you heard me play a lot
of phrases that would start--
[PLAYS F-SHARP]-- on this
pitch and end on [PLAYS E].
So you can do this--
[PLAYS PHRASE]
or [PLAYS MORE PHRASES]--
like that.
And then there are some
characteristic phrases, also,
like this-- [PLAYS PHRASES].
Those two phrases
are very common.
Even this-- [PLAYS PHRASE].
So those things, you
heard those coming
back over and over again.
How obvious they
were, I'm not sure,
but that's part of the
way we present the music.
So we can take that idea
and, in another context,
we can take like, say, a
small melodic fragment,
and use that as like a little
theme you keep coming back to
in the improvisation.
So for example, if you
take-- let me turn this off.
You take a tune-- in fact,
this happens in compositions
quite a bit.
So for example, a jazz
piece like "Tenor Madness"
by Sonny Rollins uses
a thematic fragment
that keeps coming back.
And we can also use that as
a basis for improvisation.
So I'll play that
composition and then play
a little improv using that
kind of fragment as an idea.
[PLAYS "TENOR MADNESS"]
Something like that.
You can take that little,
those themes-- [PLAYS THEME]
and [PLAYS THEME],
which is a variation,
and use that in build an
improvisation around that.
So that's kind of
an extrapolation
of the use of chalan
in Hindustani music.
OK, now, towards the end,
did anybody notice anything
different about what I did
towards the end of my alap
presentation?
AUDIENCE: You started moving
to a rhythm [INAUDIBLE]
PHIL SCARFF: Yeah,
I moved into rhythm
and I also started
repeating notes.
Like-- [PLAYS EXAMPLES].
So that's called jhala.
And even in that case, I
started with a repetition.
The pulse of the repetition,
or the rate of repetition,
was a little bit slower.
And then I built it up.
I made it faster, and
then I made it quite fast
towards the end.
So even that, there
was a note density kind
of progression in that
presentation as well.
So for jhala, where
we're repeating
notes in kind of a
rhythmic fashion,
does anybody have
any ideas about how
you might extrapolate?
What could you do differently
using that kind of concept
but changing a parameter
or two here or there?
Does anybody have any ideas?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you move the
notes around, rather than
repeat the same note?
PHIL SCARFF: You can
move notes around, right.
Rather than repeating
the same note,
you could move notes around.
That's a great idea.
And another thought I had
was, instead of repeating them
in more or less equal length,
you could vary the length.
Like you could say, play
a long note, and then
a shorter note,
and a shorter note,
and a shorter-- so you
condense down the repetition.
So maybe like-- [PLAYS EXAMPLE].
Something like that, which
is not typically done.
Usually when the jhala
starts, it kind of
starts at a moderate clip.
So that's one idea.
Or you could even slow it down.
You can start very fast and
come down to slower speed.
So some things that can
be done with that, too,
to change it around.
So then one other one other
thing is rhythmic progression.
And I think that was
already alluded to,
but I started out in
a very rubato mode,
where I was playing not
with really any time implied
and with longer notes.
And then as the note
density increased,
after a while I went
into a time and started
playing lines that were in time,
but kind of in a moderate clip.
And then after that, I went into
the jhala and the jhala built
up to a much faster
internal speed.
So there was a progression
of rhythmic ideas
as well, which, again, we can
change parameters on that.
You can start with
a very fast rhythm
and move to a slower rhythm
or something like that.
Or you could be in time
and then go out of time--
that kind of thing can be used.
OK, now another thing that
is done, another framework,
is called bistar.
And in bistar, what we do,
it's like the beginning
of the alap, where we're
playing rubato style,
but it's done over time.
So this would be after the
composition is introduced
and after the
percussion comes in
and there's a rhythmic cycle
going on at a certain speed.
The performer may elect to
play in that speed, which
would be very obvious, but then
you could also go out of time.
While the time's going on,
you can play out of time
on top of that.
That's called bistar.
I guess I won't try to
demonstrate that right now,
but that's another
idea that can be used.
OK then, there's a
technique called gatkari.
And the gat means the
composition and kari
means, like, play.
So you play with the
composition is basically
what it means, literally.
So in this case, I haven't
played the composition yet.
So what I'll do is I'll play
for you now just the first line
of a simple composition
in Hamsadhwani.
And this is in a 16 beat cycle.
[PLAYS MUSIC]
So that's the first
line of the composition.
So traditionally,
what can happen is,
you can take a line
of the composition,
and in that cycle of 16
beats, part of the cycle,
you play the composition and
then, for part of the cycle,
improvise.
So for example, you could
play the first eight
beats of the composition.
And then improvise
for eight beats.
That adds up to 16.
And then you keep
repeating that.
So it stays aligned with the
cycle of the composition.
So I'll just demonstrate a
little of that right now.
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
So that's an idea that's
called gatkari, or a framework.
And now, one thing we could
do to change it up-- well,
let me ask you.
What ideas do you have?
What could be done?
Can you think of
any ideas on how
you might change a parameter
to make it different?
Any thoughts?
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Rather than coming
back to the first half,
come back to the second half.
PHIL SCARFF: Yeah,
that's right, exactly.
You can even come back
to different points
in the composition.
So the first time
through the cycle,
maybe you improvise on
the last eight beats.
Then maybe next time
you start on beat five.
And maybe you go for
four beats and then
you come back to
the composition.
So you could do that.
You kind of mix it up and
improvise, come in and out
and improvise in
different sections.
That would be a way
to extrapolate that.
OK, and now there's another
framework called layakari.
And laya has to do
with the rhythm,
and again kari is like play.
So this is like rhythm play.
So in this framework,
what is done is,
the performer will play
different rhythmic patterns
or rhythmic combinations.
There's more emphasis on rhythm
in this particular framework.
So I've given in a
handout a few examples.
But basically, let's
take this 16-beat cycle.
I think it might make sense if
we have people clap for this.
One second.
I'll show you a
clapping pattern.
So in this rhythmic cycle,
which is called tintal,
the typical clapping
pattern is pretty simple.
It goes like this-- [CLAPS]
1, 2 3, 4, [CLAPS] 5, 6, 7, 8,
[UPSIDE-DOWN CLAP] 9, 10, 11,
12, [CLAPS] 13, 14, 15, 16.
And [CLAPS] 1.
So we're clapping
every four beats.
And the third clap
is done as a wave,
or upside down-- you
flip your hand over.
So everybody do this with me.
Let's see-- I'll
just count four beats
and we'll start at the
beginning of the cycle.
One, two, three, four--
[CLAPS] 1, 2, 3, 4, [CLAPS] 5,
6, 7, 8, [CLAPS] 9,
10, 11, 12 [CLAPS] 13,
14, 15, 16. [CLAPS]
2, 3, 4, [CLAPS]
6, 7, 8, [CLAPS] 10, 11,
12, [CLAPS] 14, 15, 16.
OK, good.
Now, what I'm going
to ask you to do
is do that clapping
pattern while I play.
So keep the time going.
So what I'll do is, I'll play
a few rhythmic combinations
and I'll play some
of them slowly,
using quarter
notes, essentially,
just so you can hear more
easily how they work.
And then I'll play some faster,
also, more like eighth notes.
So it'll give you
a little more sense
of how it might be performed.
I'll start off with
simple ones and make
it a little more
complicated as I go.
So I'll give you four
beats, and I'll probably
play the composition once or
twice just to get started.
But I'll give you four beats and
we'll start the clapping, OK?
One, two, three, four.
[PLAYS MUSIC WITH STUDENTS
CLAPPING]
OK, good.
So that's some examples
of different ways
you can set the rhythm.
You can also leave out,
in these patterns--
Well, actually, let me
play one or two more.
So for example, if you take the
one where I did three, three,
three, three, and four,
altogether it comes out to 16.
So I did three, three,
three, three, four.
So what you can do
is, if you leave out
the first note in each
set, it's like a variation.
So let's do the
clapping pattern again.
One, two, three, four.
[CLAPPING STARTS]
First I'll play the whole thing,
then I'll leave out the note.
[PLAYING MUSIC]
It's a little hard to
line up the clapping
with the improvisation
there, but that was the idea.
And so you can take that thing.
Now, does anybody have any ideas
for how to extrapolate that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You could, rather
than be in just a 16-beat cycle,
go further [INAUDIBLE].
PHIL SCARFF: Yeah, sure,
absolutely you could.
You could do two cycles.
You could do whatever,
yeah, that's true.
You can make it
a longer pattern.
I'll say that would
be probably considered
to be part of the tradition.
It's not really exactly
an extrapolation
outside the tradition.
But yes, that's a great idea.
So it's something
to think about.
This one, I haven't
really come up
with any brilliant ideas
for how to extrapolate this,
but I'm sure that in this room
there's enough mental capacity
to think of some other
ways of doing this.
So I'll leave that to
you to think about.
OK, now a few other examples.
There's a technique called
tans, or a framework
called tans, which are
basically fast lines.
And there are different
ways to build tans.
So I'm going to
demonstrate a few of those.
So first of all, you can use
just a limited number of notes,
like, say, three or four
notes to construct tans.
So then it's like,
in a confined range,
you're playing sort
of a rapid passage.
So something like this
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
Something like that
is a confined range.
And so what could
we do with that?
Well, I'm going to
kind of move along
because we need to
switch over to Ravikiran
in a couple of minutes.
So some ideas there.
You could take some tones.
Now, notice I used all
adjacent tones in the scale.
So you could take some
non-adjacent tones, maybe.
Three non-adjacent tones,
maybe with larger intervals
in between, and
use those instead.
Something like that is a
way to extrapolate that.
Then we have tans that
expand and contract.
So let me play an
example of that.
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
So there I started
low, I expanded up
a little bit above
the high tonic,
and then came back down again.
So expanding, contracting.
You can contract, expand,
those kind of things.
Some ideas for how
to extrapolate that.
OK, instead of
going in sequence,
maybe go out of sequence.
So instead of sequentially
expanding, maybe
you start with a small range,
then go to a large range,
then maybe a medium range,
then an even bigger range,
or something like that,
so you kind of mix it up.
It's an idea for
extrapolating that.
Then we have a type of tan
which is called a palta tan.
Here we take a short
melodic fragment
and repeat it going
up and down the scale,
making any necessary adjustments
to accommodate the chalan.
So for example, if we take
a simple pattern like this--
[PLAYS PATTERN] three notes--
we can make a tan out of that.
So I'll just demonstrate
how that works.
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
So something like that.
Now, that could be
extrapolated by maybe,
instead of going up
in a scalar fashion,
you go up in intervals.
Like you go up in
some sort of arpeggio.
Or maybe, instead of
picking adjacent notes,
you pick notes that have
intervals in between,
and then you take that pattern
and move it up and down
the scale.
Things like that can
be done to extrapolate.
Then finally, another type
of tan, which is frequently
used to conclude a
segment-- so we've
been doing these other
types of tans, confined
range, expanding-contracting,
palta tans,
different things like this.
We may choose to conclude
that segment by just
played a straight tan.
It goes straight up or
straight down, pretty simple.
[PLAYS EXAMPLE] Something
like that-- or [PLAYS EXAMPLE]
to conclude a segment,
that's usually used.
So that's pretty much the end
of my part of the presentation.
Are there any other questions
before we move on to our guest?
OK, yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Could you
chromaticize what you're doing?
PHIL SCARFF: Yes, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: With ornamentation?
PHIL SCARFF: Oh, yeah.
Absolutely, yeah.
You can chromaticize it.
I mean, this can be
applied to anything.
So you could do
anything chromatically.
You could use
chord progressions.
It can be free form.
You can move all around.
Yeah, anything can be
done to extrapolate.
It's really a wide
open scenario.
Yeah.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What's the instrument
that plays the background?
PHIL SCARFF: Oh, this is
an electronic tambura,
which takes the place of
the real tambura, which
is a stringed instrument which
is used to provide a drone.
In Indian classical
music, we always
have a drone going on while
the music is happening.
AUDIENCE: And is it this
resonant in the actual tambura?
PHIL SCARFF: Yeah, it is very.
Yeah, it is really
quite resonant, yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: This might be
slightly off topic, but what
are the similarities and
differences between chord
progressions in jazz versus
using a raga in Indian music?
PHIL SCARFF: Right,
so the two idioms
are very similar
in a lot of ways.
And so the way I would say you
compare a chord progression
to Indian music in,
let's say, jazz, right?
That's what you're
talking about.
So in a jazz composition,
you'll have a fixed length.
Like it might be 32
bars, for example.
And it has a particular
chord progression
that lasts for that 32 bars.
And then the cycle
begins again, and it
keeps on cycling through.
So in Indian classical
music, the analogy
is you have the tal, which
is the rhythmic cycle.
And that rhythmic cycle
has a specific structure
which goes on for
whatever number of beats.
It may be 16 beats
such as tintal,
which we got a very slight
introduction to today.
And that keeps
repeating over and over.
So the tal becomes
the structure.
And the tabla-- in
my interpretation
here, the tabla, which
is the percussion that
would perform the tal, is
playing specific strokes.
So for example in tintal,
the strokes go like this.
I can verbalize the strokes that
would be played on the drum.
It goes-- dah, din, din, dah,
dah, din, din, dah, dah, tin,
tin, tah, tah, din din, dah.
Those are the 16 beats
that define tintal.
So those strokes work
in analogous fashion
to a chord progression
in jazz, so
that it defines where
you are in the cycle
and when you're coming back
to the beginning of the cycle.
Any other questions?
OK, great, so let's
have Ravikiran come up.
PROFESSOR: Thanks, Phil Scarff.
PHIL SCARFF: Yeah, yeah.
The pitches are
essentially the same.
But they're slightly different,
because the tuning's not
identical.
In Indian classical music we
don't use even-tempered tuning.
So it's sort of
related to just tuning,
but it's not just
tuning, either.
It depends on the raga.
So there's slight
differences in the notes,
depending on the raga.
But pretty much it's the
same 12 chromatic pitches.
So for example, one
thing that happens
is, the major third is one
of the big discrepancies.
In the even-tempered
system, the major third
is, I think, 14 cents above
the major third that's
used in Indian
classical music, which
is more of a just major third.
And a similar thing happens
to the major seventh
because it's related
to the fifth.
See, the root and the fifth
would be justly tuned,
as opposed to even tempered.
So then the fifth, being
justly tuned from the root,
is the major third
below the seventh.
So the seventh also is much
flatter-- the natural seventh.
All set?
CHITRAVINA RAVIKIRAN: Yes, sir.
So good afternoon and--
can you all hear me?
So I think the
introduction that Phil
gave toward
improvisational techniques
in the North Indian
system, much of it actually
holds good in the South Indian
system of Carnatic music,
as well.
Carnatic is probably about
2000, 2500 years old system.
The origins can be traced
back to the era of the vedas
and so forth in India.
But somewhere along the line,
probably around the 1300s,
India actually developed two
distinct classical systems.
This was also
around the time when
there was a lot
of Persian guests
in the northern part of India.
So a lot of imports happened,
and a kind of a hybrid culture
developed in the
northern part of India.
That's why the two systems
of music, even today,
they have a lot of common
concepts, common roots,
common ideas, common ideals.
But the manner in which they
have evolved and developed
have varied about 700
years down the line.
So now, the concept
of improvisation,
if you can just summarize it,
it can either be purely melodic,
or it could be melo-rhythmic,
or it could be purely rhythmic.
So that's what it boils down
to in most system of music.
And so the example that Phil
played of the first period,
like the time, cycle bound but
there's no rhythm, [INAUDIBLE]
like the freestyle
improvisation,
the pure melodic
one, the alapana.
He explained to you
how beautifully it's
organized in a particular
manner from the lower notes
to the higher notes
and from slow speed
to the fastest speeds
in Hindustani music.
In Carnatic music, in fact some
of the discussions about how
it can be extrapolated were
happening, I noticed that.
But in Carnatic music,
many of these things
are already applied, in the
sense that, you don't always
start from the lower notes.
You have several
actual situations
where you start
from higher notes,
or you actually render
in faster speeds first
and then you just
come down and finish
with tranquil kind
of a feel to it.
Or the other possibility
which can also happen
is the interspersing
of these all the time.
So there are times when
you just keep interspersing
the fast and slow phrases
through the improvisation.
Now, I'll just give
an example of that.
Can you hear well
the instrument?
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
So here you see higher octave,
lower octaves fast, slow,
everything happening as
the musical dynamics keep
evolving during the course
of the improvisation.
This is very typical in many
Carnatic ragas, when you do not
really start in a slow fashion.
But the slow to
fast, low to high
also holds good in many cases.
Probably about 50-60%
of the improvisation
that we do in Carnatic
music, pure improvisation,
we do that same
kind of development.
But there are
exceptions like this,
but the exception has a good
percentage of about 30-40%
in Carnatic.
So that's one of the things.
And then if you're looking at
pure rhythmic improvisation--
today we are not having any
percussion instruments for me
to actually demonstrate
that part of it,
but it's very, very exciting,
very involved and very well
defined concepts of rhythm.
So let's actually go to the
melo-rhythmic part of it.
Prior to that, I'll
also give a parallel
of what Phil showed in
the jor and the jhala
kind of improvisation,
where we actually
do a similar kind of
development in Carnatic also.
It's like, there is
an element of rhythm,
but it's not like cyclic rhythm.
[TUNING INSTRUMENT]
This instrument
is the chitravina.
Chitravina is like
a 20-string slide.
As you can all see, the
technique of playing this
is very simple.
I'm sure that all of you
can do this in no time.
So all we do is just
slide this on the thing
and we get the notes.
I'll just show this example
of non-cyclic rhythm
but still some kind of
structured improvisation.
This is known as tanam
in Carnatic music.
It's slightly
distinct from the tan
that you just heard
in Hindustani,
where it's more
composition based.
They also have the
composition percussion
happening in that kind of thing.
But here it can be without
the percussion also.
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
Kind of thing.
So this is like as
you will notice,
there is the element
of rhythm, but it's not
like a tangible rhythm.
So this is like a semi-rhythmic
kind of improvisation.
And then we have, the
composition typically starts.
I suppose I should add here
that Carnatic music has
several times only
the composition
rendered with no improvisation.
So there are times when
we only just interpret
the composition, because
there's a very rich tradition
of several kinds of different
musical forms, which
are represented in a
typical Carnatic concert.
It's almost like Western
classical in that sphere,
except that there's no
harmony to the composition,
it's all melodic compositions.
And there's a lot of lyrics
also happening in many of them.
So many times, the
improvisation could
be optional in many
of these compositions.
And in certain
times when we do, we
can have a very
short improvisation.
For example, it could
just be like a few seconds
of the pure melodic
prelude that I just played.
And then we just go
into the composition.
And then we just move into
some improvisation alone
or on top of the compositions.
So now I'll just dwell on two
types of improvisation that's
possible in the
melo-rhythmic manner.
So once a piece starts,
the percussion joins,
and so then we get
into the cyclic rhythm.
Just like you just had this
clapping and finger counting
happening in Hindustani, we have
the similar kind of structure.
But what happens in Carnatic
is that you have the percussion
not merely keeping
time but they also
keep improvising on the
composition parallel
to what we are
playing sometimes.
So when you actually hear
it with the percussion,
you can have a very different
kind of feel to the thing.
But what I'll do now is just
demonstrate a simple tala
like a parallel of the
tintal that you just heard.
This is eight counts, so
it's known as Adi tala.
So it's [CLAPS] one,
two, three, four,
[CLAPS] five, six,
[CLAPS] seven, eight.
So it's like, first a beat,
followed by three finger counts
starting from the little
finger, and then a beat
and a wave of the hand, another
beat and a wave of the hand.
So you want to try it with me?
So [CLAPS] one, two, three,
four, [CLAPS] five, six,
[CLAPS] seven, eight.
[CLAPS] One, two, three, four,
[CLAPS] five, six, [CLAPS]
seven, eight.
So this is one of the talas.
I'll also just demonstrate
another simple tala.
It's just three counts.
[CLAPS] One, [CLAPS] two, three.
Just two beats and
one wave of the hand.
[CLAPS] One, [CLAPS] two,
three. [CLAPS] One, [CLAPS]
two, three.
So what I'll do is, I'll
take a composition in this
just for contrast, take
a small part of this
and just show how the
improvisation can happen.
One of them is with the
lyrics, because a competition
has lyrics.
So a line from the competition
is taken and melodically
developed, keeping the rhythm
and the lyrics constant.
Only the melody is
skipped, changing.
It's distinct from a melodic
variation in the context
that a melodic variation can
still have a lot of closeness
to the original line.
But here, the whole thing
can change drastically
from the original
melody, but you
keep coming back to the
original refrain of the line
that you took for
the improvisation.
So I'll just take
one competition
in the style of three counts
and just show it to you.
So you all will
keep time with me?
[CLAPS] One, [CLAPS] two, three.
[CLAPS] [CLAPS] three.
[PLAYS EXAMPLE]
So this is the main line.
[SINGS]
So this particular
composition is in Sanskrit.
[CONTINUES SINGING]
So this line can
be then changed.
[CONTINUES SINGING]
So when I play an
instrument, I'll
try and vocalize those
syllables with the kind
of plucking that I do.
[PLAYS]
So I keep going back to that.
Then a new round of
improvisation can start.
[PLAYS]
So this kind of improvisation
keeps happening many times.
In a typical concert
in Carnatic you
would also have a
melodic accompaniment,
which is, 99 out of
100 times, a violin.
The violin in is one of the
most common melodic accompanying
instruments in Carnatic music.
It's also a very often used
solo or duo instrument.
Since about late
1700s the violin
has been an integral part
of Carnatic music in India.
So oftentimes when I
play, the accompanist
will respond to
the improvisation
in his or her own way
and then I continue.
So it's almost like a
dialogue, an exchange
is built up between the main
artist and that accompanist
during these times.
And the percussion, of
course, is very dynamic.
So they keep having their
own fun when this happens.
And then the other
kind of improvisation
that can be possible in
a melo-rhythmic manner
in Carnatic is the
sol-fa improvisation.
Just like the do
re me in Western,
there are seven
notes, fundamentally.
They are known as sa,
re, ga, ma, pa, dha, ni.
Those are the seven names.
So many times we use those
notes themselves to improvise.
[SINGS]
So you just enunciate
those notes fast.
In the typical instrument,
you can just create a stroke
for every one of the notes.
[PLAYS]
So it can be just melodic.
Sometimes you can have a lot of
interesting rhythmic patterns
just like what you just saw--
maybe descending patterns,
ascending patterns of
notes, or sometimes even
kind of patterns.
And I'll just demonstrate
some patterns.
[PLAYS]
So one two three one two three
one two three one two three
one two three-- [SINGS]
they're just threes.
[SINGS]
So these are even patterns.
But if you notice,
the song is actually
starting-- it's like a
take off after 9 out of 12.
That's where this is-- one
two three four one two three
four five-- [SINGS].
So that's where the
take off point is.
So each time you ought to be
landing kind of clear on that
particular after 9.
Whatever improvisation we do,
it's like flying an aircraft.
You can go all over the place,
but unless you land properly,
it's going to be, you
know, an accident.
So you ought to really
learn how to land correctly
on the song in music
in this improvisation.
So some of these landing points
could be pretty intricate.
And then with the
intricate points,
you can really build a lot
of beautiful, interesting
mathematical patterns
which can be a lot of fun
for the artists themselves
and for the listeners as well.
Then I'll just demonstrate
some small other patterns.
[SINGS]
So this is like five
plus seven plus nine--
kind of an ascending pattern.
[SINGS]
So again, it's
like, the reverse.
Like nine, seven,
five, kind of thing.
So you can have a lot of things.
But everything I'm doing still
within this kind of framework
of only four per beat
happening right now.
Sometimes if the composition
starts on the beat,
then you can even
change over from four.
You can have fives, or
threes, or sevens, or nines,
or so many other kinds of
pulse rate can be changed.
For example, if
the same song were
to be starting in a
different point on the beat--
[SINGS]
That means you're having
five per beat there.
And then-- one two three
four five one two three four
five one two three four five one
two three one two three one two
three one two three one two
three four one two three
four one two three four.
The tempo has to
be still constant,
but within that, you
keep changing the thing.
So in Carnatic music,
one of the key things
which is distinct
from Hindustani music
is, in Hindustani music
it's legal to accelerate
doing the course
of the competition.
So you start and
then the composition
itself can be
accelerated en masse.
But in Carnatic you'd still need
to maintain the basic tempo.
But within that, you can
change the pulse rate
and you can show
different kind of speeds.
So I think I've covered
most of the basic things
in this short time.
So if you have any questions,
please feel free to.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is that the
standard way of playing it?
So you always pluck with these
two fingers and mute with--
CHITRAVINA RAVIKIRAN: No, I
pluck with these two, actually.
The first and the second finger.
And this I use
sometimes to damp.
So a note--
[PLAYS NOTE] So I can,
if I want more staccato kind
of thing. [PLAYS STACCATO]
AUDIENCE: Can you
use your thumb?
CHITRAVINA RAVIKIRAN: Thumb is
generally not so much played
in actual things.
I use the little finger
for strumming these drone,
or rhythm, strings.
Sometimes a thumb is-- actually
found thumb really should not
be, if your technique is good,
you don't really use the thumb.
In the left hand, I use it to
grip with these three fingers.
And then these two
are used to dampen
any unnecessary vibration
from the other side.
[PLAYS]
So this finger is a
very integral part
of good slide technique,
in my opinion.
Because if you don't
use this, you'll
end up always hearing
a sort of monotonous
sliding kind of quality to it.
[PLAYS] Kind of thing.
So if you want a very
gripping kind of music,
sometimes this is a
very useful to employ.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
underlying difference
between the way
ragas are described
in Hindustani versus
Carnatic music?
CHITRAVINA RAVIKIRAN:
Well, the concept
of the raga structure
as an entity
is the same for both, in
the sense that both of them
have the same kind
of approach that it's
like a melodic formula of
ascending and descending notes
in a particular
sequence and pattern.
And even a small change to
the sequence, an addition
or edition can make
it a different raga.
And that's actually the
million dollar question,
because in the West, when
we think of a major scale,
we may think of a
lot of variations
within that particular
sequence, it'll
still be within the scale.
It will still be major scale.
But in Indian music, because
it's all melodic development,
you don't just think
of it as one scale.
Even a small change
in the sequence
make it a different raga.
People actually have
asked me about this.
A lot of my Western
contemporary musicians
have come and asked me,
what is the whole rationale
of just changing one note and
calling it a different raga,
or altering the
sequence minutely,
and how does it change
the whole thing?
The analogy I can
give there, it's
like a different shade
of the same color.
If you look at an Adobe
Photoshop or something,
you just have so many shades,
like a million shades of green.
So the similar way, you can
have so many different shades
of the major scale.
So even altering a note here,
if you're a capable musician who
is well-versed in
melodic development,
then you can really create
so many different shades
of the same thing just with a
small tweak in the sequence.
And so that no two
sequences will be similar,
if you are to explore it like
that, and take it on that path.
And I'll just give you an
example, small example,
but a fairly extreme one.
[PLAYS SCALE]
Basic major scale.
Now--
[PLAYS]
So here, I only
changed the sequence.
You still have all the notes
in both ascent and descent.
[PLAYS]
So it creates a
totally different kind
of signature tune to
this particular raga.
[PLAYS]
So that's a totally different
shade of the same major scale.
It can be a very
bouncy kind of cheer.
It can be a very contained
kind of cheer, happiness.
It can be an exciting
kind of happiness.
It can be so many
different kinds of moods
that you will be able to create
with a change in sequence.
And that is one part
of the raga structure.
The other thing that makes a
raga distinct from just a scale
or a sequence
formula is the kind
of oscillations and
the ornamentation
that are in-built, or
embedded within the raga.
So in Hindustani music,
your typical oscillations
like the glide, the
mint, as they call it.
In Carnatic, you
have what is known
as the oscillation of a note.
And this oscillation is
quite distinct from a vibrato
or a tremolo or
something like that,
because sometimes it can
be much wider amplitude.
Now, the major
scale, so I'll just
show how the second, fourth,
and sixth notes are oscillated.
[PLAYS]
So the second is oscillated
between the second
and the third.
[SINGS]
[PLAYS]
Even the sixth is
oscillated like that.
And if you notice,
the seventh is
given a force which propels
it almost to the next note.
[PLAYS] So it's almost on
the higher tonic note itself.
You don't play the seventh
flat in this particular raga.
[PLAYS]
You rarely play that seventh
in a pure manner in Carnatic.
You play the third in a
pure manner many times,
you just have the natural third.
But very rarely the
seventh will be played just
naturally as such.
It'll be generally pushed
almost with a force.
So the ornamentation is a
combination of grace and force
in almost every system of music.
It can either be grace or force.
So the typical ornamentation
gives each raga
a different kind of flavor.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHITRAVINA RAVIKIRAN: No,
see, the technical term
in Indian term, Indian parlance,
is either nadai or gati.
Gati is Sanskrit.
So it's like, one two three
four, one two three four
is Chatusram.
Tha ka dhi mi, tha ka
dhi mi tha ka dhi mi.
All of these have technical
syllables and all of that.
I'm just trying to
demystify most of this
for you right now using
more simple terms.
Tha ka dhi mi, tha ka dhi mi,
tha ka dhi mi, tha ka dhi mi.
Tha ki ta, tha ki ta,
tha ki ta, tha ki ta.
Tha ka tha ki ta, tha ka
tha ki ta, tha ka tha ki ta,
tha ka tha ki ta.
Tha ka dhi mi tha ki ta, tha ka
dhi mi tha ki ta, tha ka dhi mi
tha ki ta, tha ka
dhi mi tha ki ta.
Tha ka dhi mi tha ka tha ki ta,
tha ka dhi mi tha ka tha ki ta,
Tha ka dhi mi tha ka tha ki ta.
So all this is like four,
three, seven, five and nine,
known as Chaturasram, Thisram,
Misram, Khandam, Sankeernam.
These are the different kind of
pulse rates which are possible.
These are the
traditional pulse rates
that are generally
used in Indian music.
Now, you can also
use, of course,
people are using 11, 13, and
other kinds of pulse rates
also in certain compositions.
AUDIENCE: That's
a gati or nadai.
CHITRAVINA RAVIKIRAN:
That's a gati or nadai.
In Sanskrit, gati means nadai.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When you're
improvising outside
of the Carnatic tradition,
such as a song like you
did yesterday,
"Lonely Woman," how
do you make your note choices?
What sort of thought
process is involved in that?
CHITRAVINA RAVIKIRAN: Well,
when I play with musicians
from other cultures,
from diverse cultures,
my natural inclination
would be to see
if it is like fitting into any
kind of particular sequence
pattern, or what kind
of sequence dominates.
So I'll almost think of
it like another raga.
But many times, I'll identify
one particular sequence.
Then I'll also know what notes
are outside the sequence,
so I'll have a fair idea
of how the melody is.
So that way, I think
Carnatic music--
I mean this as an
objective statement
not because I come
from the tradition--
but having collaborated
with a lot of artists,
I think that
Carnatic is probably
the most complete
melodic system.
So the kind of grounding
that you get melodically
when you learn this
system makes you versatile
enough to collaborate
with almost any other kind
of culture most of the time.
When I say Carnatic in
this particular context,
it includes the
North Indian also.
The raga system of music is
very melodically complete.
But now, when we
played "Lonely Woman,"
we had almost free style kind
of approach to it yesterday.
So that one was more easy to do.
But the other composition,
the [? domba ?] [INAUDIBLE].
There, at least, there
are certain notes
which is more like one
of the pentatonics.
[PLAYS SCALE] Or [PLAYS SCALE]
kind of thing, so there.
So it was not
difficult [INAUDIBLE].
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you
talk a little bit
about the role of dance
with Carnatic music.
CHITRAVINA RAVIKIRAN:
See, I personally believe
that, until almost 1700, dance
and music were pretty much
close in the south of India.
But then by 1700s, or
rather, the later part
of 1700s, pure
music forms started
getting more distinctive.
And started
diverging from dance.
So today the dance repertoire
and music repertoire
are pretty distinctive, with a
couple of overlaps like padams
or tillanas and javalis
and so forth happening.
But there is very, very
much of a divergence today.
That's why, if you actually
look at some composers
before Tyagaraja and others
who were more in the mid-1700s,
people like Oottukkadu Venkata
Kavi, a lot of his compositions
would be very, very
extrapolatable to dance also,
because he was much
closer to that period
when dance, drama-- I
mean theater-- and music
were pretty much integrated,
actually, almost.
AUDIENCE: This is more a
philosophical question.
When you're a
musician and you're
practicing ragas and
compositions, to what degree
can you, maybe over the
course of your career,
over rehearse to the point
where the improvisation sounds
rehearsed rather than having
that momentary brilliance
that is the beauty
of Carnatic music.
Do you see that as a problem
making Carnatic music?
That sometimes it's
improvisational,
but it's over-rehearsed
and not spur of the moment?
CHITRAVINA RAVIKIRAN:
I would say
that that's not a
problem only with any one
particular system of music.
I think in any
system of music, you
have to have a fine balance
between the necessary amount
of practice for
command and control,
but not to compromise
your personal enjoyment
or the spontaneity
and the freshness
of the thing-- for
yourself, first.
So even in, say,
piano or something,
if you really keep practicing
mechanically just the fingers,
only develop muscle memory,
then only your muscles
will be playing the
music, not your mind.
So the passion has
to still be kept up.
And that's a very
difficult thing.
Unless you, yourself,
figure it out,
it's very difficult to
have a formula for that,
like a common formula.
So each artist has to--
I mean, when I play,
if I practice for about five,
six hours, or seven hours
continuously at a
stretch, the moment
I start finding things
too effortless, I stop.
So there has to be just that 5%,
10% of effort still happening
for you to really be in it.
If it starts getting
too effortless,
it's almost mechanical.
Then you are not even there.
There has to be a certain
amount of effortlessness,
but probably about 90%
effortlessness and 10% effort
balance.
AUDIENCE: Going
back to the response
you had about
collaboration, is it
at all disorienting
that Carnatic verses you
so well in melodic
structure is it
disorienting when that
melodic structure is not
there, not the point, and in
fact the source of structure
is harmonic or something else?
I'm kind of curious
about your statement
that it trains you
well, because I've
seen where
disorientation between--
CHITRAVINA RAVIKIRAN:
No, see, you
have to really understand
two things here.
The melodic approach in the
harmonic approach are distinct
and they have their
own rationale.
each one has its
own evolution which
has been over a
period of time based
on aesthetics--
general aesthetics,
individual aesthetics
common aesthetics,
national, regional, cultural,
all kinds of aesthetics
come into play.
The melodic combinations,
from my experience,
I have seen that almost any
combination of notes played
or heard successively
can be made to work,
over a period of time.
But when you start playing
simultaneous notes, which
is more harmony, when
you start getting
into polyphonic, vertical
arrangement of notes,
there are sudden
combinations only
which can work better
than other combinations.
And even that is, you
know, so many experiments
keep happening all the time.
You will take this conventional
combinations of the three note
chords and then you start doing
so many other kinds of things.
But again, it takes
time for the ears
to start getting
adjusted to that.
Now, similarly, when you
start listening to harmony
with a melodic ear, so to speak,
or melody with a harmonic ear,
then you'll start finding
things which are disorienting
or which are not resolved.
And that's where my whole
concept of melharmony came in.
That was the rationale
when I started melharmony.
Actually you guys
can do a wiki search
on melharmony, which is a
concept I started in 2000.
My whole rationale
was that people
were hearing music with their
culture and their type of ears.
And then they would
actually find--
so suppose somebody
from the West
was hearing a melodic concept.
He may find it pretty
uni-dimensional with only one
or two melodies happening
at the same time with not
much of a vertical dimension.
And similarly, to a person
who was hearing Western music
with a raga in mind,
there'll be so many notes
which are going out of
that particular sequence
or out of the scale.
But that will
still be rationally
applicable for that
particular culture.
So what I started
doing is try to create
this system of harmony with
an emphasis on melodic rules.
That's what melharmony is.
So that's where I tried to start
reconciling that difference,
to create that bridge
between these two oceans.
But it's a very serious concept.
So melharmony has its
own separate rules
for harmony itself-- very,
very rationally explainable,
applicable rules.
And so I've been collaborating
with different orchestras,
like, say, BBC, or Sacramento
Symphony, and different kinds
of orchestras, or
with jazz groups.
So some of these compositions
that I play are melharmonic.
So there is that element
of vertical thing,
but with the emphasis
on structured rules of
[INAUDIBLE].
In fact, the Society for
Music Theory conference
in Boston in 2005--
maybe, I don't
know whether you were there in
that-- Robert Morris, the Chair
of composing from
Eastman School of Music,
presented a paper on melharmony.
So it's a very interesting
topic and subject.
PROFESSOR: I think
we'll leave it there.
Let's give a big round of
applause for Ravikiran.
[APPLAUSE]
And for Phil Scarff.
Thank you all very much.
CHITRAVINA RAVIKIRAN: Pleasure.